a visit to the dentist has become a
luxury for many people in economically
stressed Argentina
the country's one robust Public Health
Service is underfunded and overwhelmed
by demand for diminishing resources so
the University of Buenos Aires is taking
Health Care Professionals to some of the
poorest neighborhoods in the capital on
a truck and offering their services for
free
tooth infection and says the truck was
her only option
I saw on Tick Tock they were doing this
and I thought it was a good idea to have
access to something that is free dental
care is expensive and they charge you a
lot and it's difficult to afford it
Maria had two teeth removed it cost her
nothing
part of a free health care service where
professors and students from Argentina's
largest university provide assistance to
those who need it many of those coming
here today belong to the middle class
and because of the economic crisis in
this country they can no longer afford a
health insurance or dental care and
that's why this type of services are
crucial for many people in Argentina
right now and it's not just dentists
there are also ophthalmologists who
prescribe and provide glasses for free
patients come with an appointment and
for many this is the first time they see
an ophthalmologist and they've never
been in touch with one they also teach
children how to brush their teeth and
provide Veterinary assistance as many of
those who came here say they cannot
afford to pay for vaccines and other
medicines for their pets
is the organizer of the program he says
Argentina's Healthcare System is in a
deep crisis
Public Health has been a pillar of
Argentina and today it's facing many
difficulties it's difficult to get an
appointment in the hospital it's
difficult to get an appointment for
surgery and it's also difficult to get a
tooth extraction and we try to give
solutions to those problems as people in
Argentina are trying to cope with an
inflation rate of over 120 percent in
the past year some Health Care
Professionals are trying to give back to
the community some of the services many
desperately needs